[Music]
alright and Kat Von trouble news I did
too
she's a great artist by the way look go
on it's submitted by Sunday mornings you
guys sound just like maroon 5 Kat Von D
defends herself against allegations of
being a quote-unquote Nazi and an
anti-vaxxer who's who's Kat Von D she is
a tattoo artist used to have a tea TV
show celebrities is blind Hugh oh really
vegan laundry later smelly ink yeah yeah
that was her so she started on Miami Ink
yeah and then she got a spinoff in LA
called la ink and she's been accused of
a lot of things over the years she said
a lot of controversies she had a
controversy with Jeffrey star and she
had like a lot of stuff she's always
like in the in the got controversy sir
yeah in the tea circles yes she has been
accused of being an anti-semite before
and she's been accused of being an
anti-vaxxer and that's her choice letter
Nazi is you know that's extremely she
works with needles but she's the anti
pastor if you don't if you don't fax
your kid and then you sign of school
with a lot of other kids and then some
of those kids have autoimmune diseases
true yeah yeah yeah yeah but I mean
that's still it's not like a horrible
thing it's just dumb it's Donald what it
is is stupid because some people think
it's childhood some people think it's
child abuse a lot of people think it's
reverting us back to like the polio days
and like bringing a lot of diseases back
that were almost eradicated
child though because if my kid already
has vaccinations for polio but some like
she was saying that audio means yeah
some people can't get vaccinated so like
kids with autoimmune disease especially
really young ones and elderly people
can't get vaccinated even though they
didn't get the vaccine because it wasn't
invented yet
they're not allowed to get it still yeah
yeah so that's the controversy there are
a lot of anti-vaxxer laberd e's that's
where that vaccinations gave their kid
autism and like there's a lot of
different back-and-forth not the [ __ ]
coke and all the drugs that they did and
all their choices his parents but where
there's a lot like you could research it
because having kids are like 50 years
aware that it was the facts that ruined
their kids it's a lot of things after
that she did the anti vaccine which was
a couple years ago I think like a over a
year ago at least she said that she
wasn't gonna vaccinate her child her
sales started dropping like crazy so
this video seemed to come out of nowhere
because no one was even talking about
her no one's calling her an anti vaccine
right now no one's calling her an
anti-semite so but all of a sudden she
puts out this video that says I'm I am
NOT a Nazi and I'm not an anti-vaxxer
and in the video she explains why she's
been accused of being a Nazi and she
says really hurtful because when she was
on Miami Ink she was like the only girl
and crowd of guys and the guys were kind
of getting jealous that she was stealing
the limelight so they framed her as if
she signed this headshot saying like see
you in Hell Jew bag or something like
that it was like a really anti-semitic
message but she's like I did not write
that that was another guy that was
trying that's trying to frame me cuz he
went to the cops about or not the cops
that he went to like the press about it
mama yes there was a lot of drama and
her PR team basically was like don't
comment on it just let it go away and
but it like really hurt her it's jus bag
a bad word first of all that that is a
hilarious insole
because there's somebody looked at me
and say listen to me UK bag like a crib
like bro that's how yeah what is Jew bag
mean I don't know like like I never I
never really heard about oh you know
what it is just because some people use
the word Jew as an insult
so you [ __ ] Jew bag like your
cheapest [ __ ] maybe you should beg cuz
Jew bag is hilarious I'm not Jewish
there are a lot of slurs for Jewish
people but Jew bag doesn't seem like you
even a bad word you can say it a lot
maybe it is meaningless to us like it's
setting up in a derogatory comment like
the word bloody is supposed to be bad oh
bloody hell but it means nothing to me
oh right truth it sounds like it's
somebody just out of like a quick insult
in a fight some was like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jew bag so she was like very like
hey that wasn't me that even wrote that
I was being slandered also she was
talking about how she's actually latina
and she even spoke Spanish in the video
to like kind of prove she was latina
she's like I know I look white but like
she speaks a lot of spin it I'm latina
I'm a proud latina looks great and she
said she's not anti Beck's but she just
had read a lot of news about
vaccinations and she was too scared to
do that to her baby and now she's
working with a pediatrician to make
choices but she's learned not to
disclose anything she's gonna do with
her child in the future there was
anybody even asking this [ __ ] about it I
didn't see it's trending on Twitter or
anything no you're sort of saying no no
one was at this all happened all the
drama where she was all over the place
was like a year ago
yeah and people are saying she only made
this video to put our name back in you
know that like sales could go back up
because her sales dramatically dropped
because of the Jew bag thing mmm because
the answer back
so they're okay with there being an
anti-semite semi but not but
anti-vaccine so here's what happened
after she puts this video out the way I
think a Jew egg would be very expensive
Jubilee Hills argument to say that we
like the Jew bag that I think is a
expensive that argument was not in the
video she should have put it in there
because I didn't she's like I by the way
I didn't do it but if I did a Jew bag is
very expensive it's very expected it's
it's Rodeo Drive yeah cuz when you think
of that you don't think poor you don't
think swap me you think luxurious you
think of pile of pennies in juvie and
fighting them yeah like this I don't
have a car with a bag of gold oh I feel
like it's a designer bag by a famous
Jewish artist oh the Jews bag you know
like I don't know like if it was a china
bag I'd be like whoa Giovanni Versace
yeah with the whole anti-semite thing
what is the the racist equivalent to
stop being said to them because when I
hear people install Jewish people it's
like oh you're [ __ ] Jew is [ __ ] it
means you the means you have a lot of
money well people will use it as a slur
for being yeah are you trying to Jew me
Oh cuz I hear like Jew and I always
picture is the richest people in LA
right you don't think you don't think
like bad stereotype you think like on me
you think like Beverly Hills people tied
to the movie industry you think a cake
family big family curly sideburns curly
sideburns you know oh they're just using
it as a way to be like see she hates
Jews like to paint you know painter as
an anti-semite because that's like what
slur do you use I guess besides hike or
whatever well I mean there is a I gotta
think but I could figure out something
so what happened was she puts out this
video people who don't really know about
the drama they're like wow that's so sad
that she had to go through that and they
like you it feels very heartfelt and
everything and then other people were
like wait wait wait wait wait I've been
a fan for a long time here's why I'm not
a fan anymore
she didn't even bring up this other
stuff one that she used to
data guy named Jesse Jesse James Jesse
James who was like unknown of
anti-semite Oh was he he was accused of
it center public bird got kids with him
yeah and then her current husband has a
swastika on his neck who he says as a
Hindu sign but he's not Hindu at all is
he white though he is his mother's side
has a [ __ ] eagle Hitler's Iron Cross
he's not white like blue eyes or
anything like no no no looks Hispanic
yeah he's his mother Chinese from Mexico
his and then his he says his father's
side is Jewish that's in his argument on
the Instagram but he doesn't look quite
sure what the haters are saying they're
like yo your husband has a [ __ ]
swastika on his neck you have a picture
of the husband yeah because the swastika
is supposed to be facing a certain way
well it's not facing the right though a
swastika way oh then it is Hindu right
and he says that he used to practice
yoga and so it's sitting on the lotus
flower' they would see the swastika
right you don't even look like a Nazi he
looks like a fashionista he looks like a
cholo yeah he looks I told you Far East
Movement like just because you're
Mexican doesn't mean you're not an
anti-semite that's a stretch I don't
know any Mexicans are anti-semites
because they don't run into each other
they're like what's a Jew I don't even
that would suck he's like a Hindu sign
and you see a bunch of racist white
people like fight on brother and then
the other thing is she had a lipstick
color out that she named selection which
was spelled the German way which was
like a really bad word for how they used
to pick which Jews they were gonna kill
in the Holocaust so it's it's not a word
that you even use in Germany at all like
selection
yeah selection just be like that sounds
like a Spanish word for selections mean
selection but it's a German word it's
not with Ches in the middle that
collects spell it that way that's a
stretch
this could have been from ignorance and
the cake could have been because her
name is Kat Von D so you know people
they want to put the name of the it was
spelled exactly like the selection
that's hard that's hard because if it
was a Spanish select yeah no we don't
use a K we look at Lisa C so unless
y'all yeah it was your double K's in the
middle how they sell it in Germany when
they're talking about pop you know who
she reminds me of this is dude in
Sacramento she runs it from me know what
this guy is so [ __ ] dumb right writes
a message to me I'm not gonna say my
four anymore because this is so [ __ ]
stupid somebody wrote a blog about how
he behaved when he was a part of these
college like fraternities and how he
would like kind of hit on these chicks
in a sleazy type of way it sounds like a
fraternity and they kind of like looked
up to him because he was very outspoken
about you know whatever certain like
women's rights or whatever and I guess
he slept with a couple of them he was
like hey I'm not to put out a public
statement and I literally wrote to him
in the nicest way possible I was like
who the [ __ ] are you nobody cares what
are you Republican to what public is
reading it exactly and I was like I got
to write a public statement I hit up a
lawyer I was like what is going on no
you're nobody thirty people I let my
fans down I got it I got a right this
wrong nobody cares what are you did you
even write to the girl specifically he
was dull
dude go do that jackass like what's
really talking to me what would you do I
was like I'm also nobody nothing Gemini
either Gemini I don't I don't do that
but I don't know maybe I what are you
supposed to do like if something happens
because you did something in the past
and it's like you can't even tell your
story if someone's accusing you of
something yeah are you talking about Kat
Von D or his friend that Cody's if she's
gonna come out and say here's why I'm
not an anti-semite
she should have explained all of these
anti-semitic things it wasn't written
because people were like it was we
didn't think you're an anti-semite
because of this headshot
it was all these incidents lined up
together and that she never defended any
of them and then she the one she picked
out of all of them was
even the one people were hounding her
for oh she should have read her comment
I think she did know what one's and she
was purposely avoiding them she's
picking them as food because like people
like me who don't keep up with it and I
just I had heard that people were saying
she's an anti-semite I think she comes
out with this video I'm like oh that
explains it and then I saw all these
other videos I was like oh [ __ ] she
didn't explain it's a slippery slope to
go down though because if you address
every you know accusation then that you
gotta you gotta stay consistent with
that but at the same time it just seems
like it was more of a publicity stunt
yes did stir up old [ __ ] such a weird
thing to do it's like tomorrow I just
put out a video that says I beat up
everybody in the LBGT community it's
gonna stir up some [ __ ] though right
it's like I beat up so many gay people
you have no idea how lucky you are to
that video yeah literally just find them
all again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]